how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it's been a while but I have a D C video
today
don't worry Marvel content isn't going
anywhere it will always be the priority
but I got a lot of requests to do a
joker spoiler free review and the movie
was just so dang good that I have to do
it I got a really cool Marvel video
coming out in a couple of hours so stay
tuned for that but Joker as I said this
is a spoiler free review I will not be
spoiling anything about the movie
so now that we got that out of the way
this movie is fantastic it has to be the
best movie that has come from DC in
years with the exception of Wonder Woman
but they are very different films it's
about author flick losing his mind going
psychotic and becoming the Joker that we
know from the comics and it is honestly
probably one of the realest movies that
I've seen now I won't dive too big into
the psychology of everything because I
don't want to ruin it but this is a
psychological thriller and as you see
author flick become bad you get happy
and it's really weird because you start
to root for him the more bad that he
gets that was something that was truly
amazing about this film while I was
watching this movie I felt so bad for
author flick and you were almost pissed
off for him and as he begins to lose it
you root for him you want him to lose it
and you find yourself rooting for a
psychopath which is just amazing
direction by the director so the biggest
thing that I truly enjoyed about the
movie is I really did not know what was
going to happen but I thought I did I
went into the movie thinking that I knew
exactly what was going to happen I knew
how the story was going to unfold but I
definitely did not they throw in a few
twists that you just really don't see
coming and they're really really good
and they happen quite frequently
throughout the film not too much but
just enough so they keep you on the edge
of your seat there are some slow scenes
in this movie that are very fitting for
the film this is not a complaint these
scenes are very necessary and I enjoyed
them even though they were slower but
the scenes where things get crazy are
awesome and warning about the film it's
violent and its gory so if you have
young kids I definitely would not
recommend taking them to see it this is
not a typical Joker movie this is not
about a clown
terrorizing Batman this is about a man
who is down on life and snaps it and
become psychotic and then becomes the
Joker and of course we know through
other movies that the Joker ends up
becoming a villain and a mass murderer
but having said that they do tie it into
Batman I won't say how but they did it
in the perfect way it wasn't too subtle
to where you missed it but it wasn't too
big to where it took away from the movie
and again just when you thought you knew
what was going to happen the movie took
a different turn it's full of just
shocking surprises and seriously Joaquin
Phoenix nailed the part for his role in
this movie as Joker he is definitely
going to be nominated for some awards
but he will probably win them as well to
truly get to the mindset of somebody who
is down on life and life is against him
and bad thing after bad thing after bad
thing keeps happening to the point to
where you snap and lose it and become
psychotic that's insanely hard and it
takes a toll on you mentally I read in
an article that Joaquin Phoenix would
have nightmare after nightmare about all
of the scenes that he shot as the Joker
so it does take a lot to get into that
characters mindset but he does an
absolutely amazing job I can't imagine
anybody else playing this part but him
and really overall I just loved the
movie everything was great it pushed all
of the boundaries probably broke a lot
of them but it didn't feel like it was
it didn't feel like they were trying to
do that it just felt like a very real
movie and I thoroughly enjoyed it and
will most likely go see it again and
will definitely be buying it on blu-ray
when it comes out so I hope you enjoy to
my spoiler free review of the Joker I
will be doing an ending explained video
for Joker later on today and like I said
I have a Marvel video coming out in a
couple of hours so stay tuned for that
and of course if you would like a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel leave a comment
on this video and like it as well to
enter my giveaway also if you'd like a
chance to win a Nintendo switch you can
follow me on Twitter and click the link
in the description down below as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
forth